[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando eu tinha 24 anos
eu fui diagnosticada com uma pessoa que
poderia enfartar qualquer momento
eu era advogada e trabalhava no mercado
financeiro
eu não era uma pessoa estressada eu não
era mau humorada e eu não tinha nenhum
indício de banal ti mas fato é que o
estresse estava consumindo a minha
vitalidade de uma forma que nem eu pude
perceber isso começou a me fazer pensar
que talvez outras pessoas tivessem
vencido também estão em 2015
foi feita uma pesquisa pela internet na
estréia de eventos sociais chan e que
resultou em 72% das pessoas estavam
infelizes com o que faziam e aí a gente
pensa em tecnologia e as previsões
antigamente era que com o passar dos
anos as máquinas viriam transferir
nossas aliadas e diminuírem a nossa
carga de trabalho em até 50%
estamos em 2018 e eu duvido muito que
alguém aqui tenha conseguido reduzir sua
carga de trabalho de 50 por cento em
2018 a pesquisa foi feita novamente
quantos porcento vocês acham que
continuam infelizes com o que fazem
somos 90%
estamos em 2018 e hoje a cada dez
pessoas nove estão infelizes com que
fazem a organização mundial da saúde
começou a se preocupar com esse tema e
fez uma pesquisa sobre os gastos que
estão sendo utilizados é o que o que os
pais quanto os países estão utilizando
de dinheiro para bancar essa
infelicidade
e o resultado é de que foram gastos 800
bilhões de reais com afastamentos por
depressão
o brasil de todos os países do mundo
está em segundo lugar nesse ranking só
perdendo para os estados unidos
dos 800 milhões 260 bilhões foram gastos
pelo brasil com afastamento de
funcionários por depressão e quando a
gente encara esses dados a gente fica se
questionando por que será que a gente se
assusta tanto
com isso porque será que talvez aqui
nesse ambiente e em cada ambiente que a
gente freqüente por aí
noventa por cento das pessoas não estão
felizes com que estão exercendo e aí a
gente tem que voltar um pouco na
história e lembrar de que nas épocas
tribais
as pessoas que não eram aceitas dentro
das tribos elas não sobreviviam então
não será aceito no grupo era significado
de morte e ao longo dos anos a gente foi
ensinado de que a gente precisava ser
aceito
o maior medo do ser humano hoje não se
aceito porque a gente herdou esse medo
da sobrevivência a gente até ela a
aceitação a sobrevivência até hoje
e aí o que a gente faz com isso a gente
começa a seguir diversos padrões na e
como é que a gente se veste por que esse
destino dessa forma a gente consegue ser
aceito em determinado ambiente como é
que a gente fala como é que a gente se
porta como é que eu faço para ser aceito
e aí essa aceitação começa a frustrar a
gente porque com o avanço da tecnologia
o que aconteceu a gente ficou cada vez
mais conectado a gente não consegue mais
fugir de quem a gente é a gente não tem
todo sendo vigiado por todo mundo assim
como a gente consegue se conectar com
todas as pessoas em qualquer lugar do
mundo então a gente não consegue mais
exercer aquela história de que quando a
gente está trabalhando a gente exerce um
papel né
e quando a gente está em casa a gente
exerce outro então a minha vida
profissional é uma coisa minha vida
pessoal é outra
isso não existe mais
tudo o que você fala tudo que você prega
e tudo o que você come tudo o que
acontece na sua vida está sendo validado
o tempo todo por todas as pessoas que te
conhecem principalmente aquelas que não
dê conhecem porque a gente não vai
conseguir fugir disso a tecnologia está
trazendo essa realidade pra gente e aí
como é que a gente lida com o fato da
gente não poder mais exercer um papel a
gente cria papéis para que a gente
consiga ser aceito nos lugares que a
gente frequenta e agora vem a tecnologia
diz olha não existe
mas o papel porque você pode estar aqui
fazendo alguma coisa e dizendo que você
faz alguma coisa e amanhã vai ter alguém
validando isso aí você não vai conseguir
pegar mais esses papéis
então o que a gente faz a gente aprende
assim a gente mesmo
a gente aprende que o melhor jeito da
gente aceita nos lugares e no trabalho
na nossa família é a gente conseguindo
exercer o nosso melhor papel que é o
nosso que é aquele que a gente sabe
fazer que aquele que a gente não precisa
se esforçar e como é que a gente não se
esforça pra isso
a gente queria vulnerabilidade nos
espaços que a gente frequenta que quer
dizer criar vulnerabilidade quer dizer
que a gente pode ter fraquezas que a
gente pode ter vitórias e que não tem
problema nenhum compartilhar isso com as
pessoas que estão ao seu redor e o
problema é a gente fica insistindo de
que nos ambientes de trabalho a gente
não pode ter fraqueza pra gente provar
que a gente conquistou alguma coisa a
gente não pode dizer que a gente teve
medo e vulnerabilidade eu poder dizer
pra vocês que não é fácil daqui não faça
subir neste palco eu tive medo eu tive
vergonha eu chorei
não foi fácil pra mim está tudo bem
porque eu sei que eu tenho uma rede de
pessoas que continuam me aceitando desse
jeito porque eu aceito elas com essas
fraquezas também tenho uma rede de
pessoas que eu sei que se eu sair daqui
agora sem ter falado nada vão continuar
mamando desse jeito não tem problema eu
não preciso exercer papel nenhum aqui em
cima e aí o que a gente faz a gente
começa a perceber que a vida pessoal ea
profissional vão ser a mesma coisa
porque a gente vai estar em todos sendo
vigiado sendo validado é mais fácil que
a gente seja a gente mesmo
é mais fácil que a gente consiga atrela
no nosso trabalho momentos de
vulnerabilidade momentos de
pertencimento com as pessoas que estão
ao nosso redor
pra que a gente aceite elas do jeito que
elas são e
o que a gente seja aceite desse jeito
também eu comecei a pesquisar bastante
esse tema e falar muito sobre isso em
diversas empresas e uma das empresas que
eu fui eu estava no elevador e eu
conheci o senhor antônio no elevador e
quando eu cheguei na reunião o tema era
como que a gente consiga integrar mais a
equipe e deixar a equipe mais motivada e
a primeira pergunta que eu fizera vocês
conhecem o senhor antonio do elevador e
aí me disseram que não
ninguém conhecia o senhor antonio
senhora antônia o senhor de 75 anos que
há cinco anos trabalhava naquele
elevador todos os dias limpando elevador
ele tinha pedido para a empresa para ser
contratado depois que a mulher dele
faleceu porque ele não queria se sentir
sozinho e ninguém conhecia o senhor
antônio
eu tenho certeza que depois daquele dia
todas aquelas pessoas passaram a
conhecer o senhor antônio se
interessaram pela história do senhor
antonio santoro nunca mais vai se sentir
sozinho ea gente precisa fazer isso onde
a gente está a gente precisa conhecer os
seus antonius a gente precisa contar
histórias nossas querem mais uma
história da minha menina que nasce
sou filha de pais separados a minha mãe
tinha 21 anos quando eu nasci e eu
cresci junto com ela num trabalho que
ela fazia com a população de rua e
equipes muito o que crescer na vida e
fazer uma carreira e fazer e se aceita
né
é isso que todo mundo quer no fundo eu
entendi que para ser aceita eu tinha que
fazer aquela carreira que todo mundo
achava que era certa e eu estudei
direito e eu irei advogada e eu comecei
a trabalhar no mercado financeiro e eu
conquistei todos os caras que eu podia
ter conquistado bem nova
e aí eu percebi que eu queria largar
tudo de repente minha vontade eu não
estava feliz mas eu queria mudar
e eu fiz isso e eu fiz o mesmo sem o
apoio de ninguém eu fiz isso para
trabalhar com algo que eu já tinha
aprendido desde criança era trabalhar
dentro do terceiro setor e hoje as
pessoas acreditam que eu faço porque sou
eu porque demorou muito pouco tempo para
as pessoas começarem a entender que
agora sim eu estava exercendo o meu
melhor papel
eu estava exercendo o papel de seu mesmo
de seu nome é a melhor versão ea
tecnologia não está longe disso porque
recentemente eu fiz uma pesquisa e eu
identifiquei que eu e meu sócio a gente
tem 59 grupo swatch zapping comum a
minha carga horária não diminuiu em 50%
a minha carga horária muito maior do que
antes porque hoje eu não estou na
estatística da da usp por exemplo que
identificou que segunda feira de manhã é
o dia com mais enfartes e porque é isso
porque as pessoas não conseguem mais
suportar a ideia de que elas têm que
acordar na segunda feira de manhã e
vestiu o papel que elas precisam vestir
e isso não significa que vocês precisam
pedir demissão que a gente precisa
transformar nossa vida então agora vai
todo mundo trabalhar com que ama
viajando pelo mundo
isso só significa que se você se permite
ouvir as histórias dos senhores antônio
que estão sentados do seu lado e se você
puder compartilhar sua história com as
pessoas estão sentadas do seu lado você
não vai mais precisar exercer papéis
porque você vai poder olhar as pessoas
do jeito que elas são e elas vão te
olhar do jeito que você é e aí o
trabalho ele é mais uma coisa agradável
que você faz ao longo do seu dia e só ea
gente costuma ter muito medo de contar
as nossas fraquezas a gente acha que a
gente vai perder alguma coisa eo que a
gente ganha uma grande rede de pessoas
uma grande rede de suporte que vai estar
com a gente e que ainda que a gente
tropeça por aí a gente sabe que a gente
tem essas pessoas que aceitam a gente
como a gente é porque nenhum momento a
gente diz pra elas que a gente não errar
então a gente precisa dentro das nossas
relações de trabalho é primeiro a
aceitar que a nossa carga de trabalho
não vai diminuir as máquinas vêm pra
serem aliadas mas elas não vão de forma
nenhuma substituir passos de amor
substituir histórias como a história do
senhor antônio e o que aquele time pode
fazer depois que descobriu a história do
senhor antônio então que a gente
primeiro aceite isso nossa carga horária
vai aumentar cada vez mais porque a
gente trabalha pela desapego e porque as
pessoas sabem quando foi a última vez
que a gente ficou online porque as
pessoas sabem se na hora que a gente
estava dizendo que a gente estava
fazendo alguma coisa do trabalho a gente
estava online ou não a gente não
consegue mais fugir
então a gente vai trabalhar o tempo todo
se a gente vai estar o tempo todo
conectado com todas essas questões
porque a gente só num se permitisse a
gente mesmo e e ali a isso o nosso
trabalho porque a gente não se permite
contar histórias nossas e ouvir
histórias nos nossos ambientes porque
quando a gente tá com os nossos amigos e
quando a gente está com a nossa família
eu não vejo ninguém contando as horas
nossa hoje eu passei três horas e meia
com os meus amigos quem faz essa conta
então porque a gente sai do trabalho
fala caramba eu trabalhei 10 horas
caramba de trabalhar 12 horas
tem pessoas lá são tão agradáveis quando
seus amigos que têm histórias tão
extraordinárias quanto dos seus amigos e
se você se permite conviver com eles
ouvir essas histórias se não vai mais
precisar quanto contar quanto tempo você
está lá porque você vai curtir essa
jornada
a gente não tem que curtir só ao final
dela a gente tem que curtir a jornada
inteira ea gente faz isso não só na
nossa vida como nosso dia então a minha
jornada de trabalho eu tenho que fazer
as minhas funções e aí eu saio e eu vou
curtir na vida também né
eu tenho essa jornada que eu quero
atingir aquele objetivo ea gente não
curte a jornadas que são a maior parte
da nossa vida
se a gente encarar isso de um jeito
diferente
talvez a gente consiga suportar essa
jornada de trabalho é muito mais alta
que a gente já entendeu que a gente vai
ter e vai ficar mais fácil
e não se esqueçam que junto com você
comigo tem várias outras pessoas que
estão buscando encontrar em algo que
elas gostam de fazer isso não significa
que elas querem mudar o que elas fazem a
gente quer mudar o como a gente faz
não interessa o que a gente faz se a
gente estiver curtindo como vai ficar
muito mais fácil
a organização mundial da saúde previu
que em 2020 a depressão vai ser a maior
causa de afastamento e eu tenho uma meta
que em 2020 eu quero transformar essa
previsão
e eu quero encontrar vocês lá pra gente
se lembrar que a gente conseguiu
transformar isso e para isso vou fazer
um pedido
quando vocês chegarem à mãe no trabalho
contém as histórias de vocês obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]